If you have a Syrian leader who commits murder and you make a gesture,
what should you do?
You can be sure that 90 of the Swiss or French population will say that
we have to kick them all out and close the borders and that they will die.
If we think now on a country-wide basis,
I believe that direct democracy,
that is,
essentially command-based piloting,
which many people think is what would get us out of the crisis,
would be a catastrophe?
It hurts.
I wish that's a good thing,
but it's not true.
In fact,
public opinion very often reacts in a populist,
security and reactionary manner.
If you have a Syrian leader who commits murder and you make a gesture,
what should you do?
You can be sure that 90 of the Swiss or French population will say that
we have to kick them all out and close the borders and that they will die.
And so that is unfortunately the problem we face.
Because to believe that it is simply a lack of
democracy and that if the good people that we are had the power,
then we would be generous,
reasonable,stic,
etc.
is just not true.
In fact,
this is just not true.